et on va direction moscou vladimir
poutine est en train de s'exprimer suite
un conseil de défense qui l'a tenu à
mener les organisations d'opération
et il semblerait que nous soyons
aujourd'hui d'une troisième source de
tension dans cette option militaire dans
cette région et je voudrais souligner
que toutes ces années les habitants de
ces régions ont fait
l'objet de brimades juge un blocage
des tirs des tirs d'artillerie régulier
comme vous le savez nous et personnes
qui vivent sur le territoire proche des
animaux de grand talent mais on était
forcés d'habiter dans leur cave d
habiter avec leurs enfants sains force
de tout ces brimades ou dépérir non pas
que sa soeur venus
depuis
cela il ya eu des négociations de parler
il s'est formé il se crée non ce que
nous le souverain première vacation
qui est une tentative de parvenir à la
paix mais tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui lille je montre que le
pouvoir de kiev n'a pas l'intention de
mettre en oeuvre les accords de whisky
gina lancé à manier de manière répétée à
plusieurs reprises à très haut niveau au
plus haut niveau de l'état au niveau du
ministre des affaires étrangères au
niveau du 11 juillet au conseil de
sécurité dont une est clair pour chacun
que ce qu'
il n'y a aucune intention de ne pas rien
de mettre en oeuvre concrètement les
accords de m néanmoins la russie a mis
en oeuvre un certain nombre d'efforts et
continue à mettre en oeuvre un certain
revenu afin de résoudre whisky toutes
ces questions complexes et tous ses
aspects tragiques
de manière pacifique mais
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous avons
second pouvant s'installer ce que nous
avons
notre réunion d'aujourd'hui
et d'antan dire non core est réglé moi
je les décideurs des miens jours que
nous à les répandre sur ce front
je parle
de ceux ci demandent qu'à dresse à la
russie les républiques populaires de
donner ce qu'ils veulent ou gasquet
demande de reconnaître leur suzerain
mais également la décision de la demande
sur ce même sujet
l'appel adressé au président au chef de
l'état le reconnaître la souveraineté et
l'indépendance des républiques
populaires
en même temps je voudrais qu'ils
sont bien sûr pratiquement liés aux
objectifs bien sûr ce sont des questions
différentes mais elles sont
intrinsèquement
globaux milieu a pu laisser que le
rythme à la fois dans le monde mais en
particulier sur le continent européen
le crème utilisée en tant qu'instrument
à l'aide de l'instrument j'ai une
contradiction à la russie ni ça c'est
une question que nous voyons comme une
menace sérieuse une menace et c'est très
important pour la russie et c'est pour
cela que depuis un certain nombre de
moindres javols un peu
active et nous avons intensifié notre
dialogue avec nos partenaires
outre atlantique au niveau de l'otan
pour parvenir à la sécurité pour
parvenir à un développement pacifique
tranquille
dans un contexte tectonique sérénité du
pays il nous faut la sécurité il me faut
créer des conditions pour
manger
il faut que nous comprenions la
réalité du contexte dans lequel nous
vivons
j'ai déjà eu aussi j nous sommes
confrontés à la menace de l'accession de
l'ukraine à l'otan a le temps on
l'admission de l'écrivain le temps et
bien nous considérons que la menace pour
notre pays sera lorsque nous coup je
suis importante parce que l'article 5 de
la charte de l'otan jeune fille indique
que tous les membres de l'alliance
doivent faire la guerre du côté de la
revente au jeu puisque deux personnes
on a fait le boulot considère que les
demandes des habitants de crime duc de
la criée sont légitimes et bien il
existe toujours un risque que le cren
tente de récupérer la crimée par les
moyens militaires
d'ailleurs cette possibilité est indiqué
dans les documents du kring lyon qu'à ce
moment là
tout
le temps sera obligée de se joindre à
cette opération à ses opérations
militaires nous allons nous dit que
certains membres de l'otan sont contre
l'adhésion de l'ukraine je t'en met
néanmoins en 2008 à bucarest un
mémorandum a été signé et ce mémorandum
ouvre les portes de l'otan à l'ukraine
et la géorgie et lorsque je pose la
question pourquoi avez-vous fait cela je
ne reçois aucune réponse et ce manque de
réponse sera lieu sous la pression des
états unis
si les membres de l'otan ont fait
quelque chose une fois sous la pression
de l'état demi où est la garantie pour
nier que cela ne se reproduira pas il
n'y a aucune garantie d'ailleurs de rien
puisque les états unis refusent
allègrement les documents qu'il sait une
beaucoup d'obligations qu'ils prennent
mais il faut certains éléments qu'ils
soient formalisées sur le papier sous
forme de droit international d'un
document qui serait valable en tant en
termes de droit international et pour le
moment nous n'arrivons pas à obtenir
cela alors voilà comment nous allons
travailler aujourd'hui je vais d'abord
passer la parole à sergueï lavrov
parce que c'est celui qui tente
aujourd'hui de trouver des accords sur
les garanties de sécurité avec
washington et avec bruxelles ensuite je
donne je passerai la parole à dimitri
kozak
pour qu'ils nous informent
une évaluation de ce qui se passe
en termes de pourparlers et de mise en
oeuvre de désaccord 2010
chacun aura ensuite l'occasion de
s'expliquer mais ce qui nous appartient
de faire aujourd'hui c'est de décider
de la marche à suivre pour nous compte
tenu du contexte compte tenu de la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons il comment nous évaluerons le
développement de cette situation
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président chers collègues
comme je lui dis au président il ya une
semaine nous avons préparé
des propositions mais garantir des
sécurité
que nous avons reçues suite aux
initiatives
de la russie datant de la fin de l'année
dernière la réaction de nos collègues
occidentaux
démontrent qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à
accepter
heureusement les propositions qui sont
cruciales pour noms tel nom
élargissement de l'otan vers l'est alors
cette demande est réfutée compte tenu de
la politique des portes ouvertes de le
temps et il n'y a aucune alternative
dans les réponses que ce soit des états
unis que ce soit de l'otan pour résoudre
cette question
le principe
de la sécurité
indivisible pour tout ce
qui est crucial pour nous les etats unis
c'est de le contourner l'absence de
principes
il ignore complètement la condition clé
pour le sociétique
personnes au moment du choix d aller en
soit d'autres moments n'a le droit de
renforcer sa propre sécurité aux dépens
de la sécurité dans notre et c'est pour
cela qu'à la fin du mois de janvier nous
avons adressé à tous nos collègues de
l'europe occidentale à la suisse où nos
collègues à nos collègues américains
oppose à l'union européenne nous n'avons
envoyé une réponse avec une autre
analyse des documents des instruments
juridiques qui avait été pris au niveau
de l'est cee
et notre analyse de relation avec le
temps passé sur la déclaration en russie
otan de 1997 et l'initiative de rim rome
qui avait été
validée par le conseil autant j'ai
un autre as laissé loge
ça concerne les relations avec le temps
en 1900 et les documents de 1997 qui dès
qu'il a déclaré que la russie et l'otan
n'étaient plus des adversaires il
s'agissait de construire un partenariat
est comprise dans le marianne
stratégique et compte tenu de cela nous
avons choisi de revenir à la
configuration
des forces de l'alliance
qui avait lieu qui existait en 1997 cet
argument a été réfutée a même titre que
le premier où
donc leur réponse le temps de nous ont
appelés à arrêter l'occupation de la
crimée à retirer nos troupes de la
géorgie de l'ukraine de la moldavie du
territoire de ces trois états en ce qui
concerne l'ukraine
les accords de ning ce sont encore une
fois a souligné dans ses réponses mais
d'une manière tout à fait récurent rick
sans aucune intention d'obliger kiev à
respecter les dispositions de ce
document qui est extrêmement important
en évidence
les réponses n'exclut pas la possibilité
de déployer idée d'armement aux
frontières de la russie mais cela le
dîner améridiens ont proposé de rouvrir
des négociations sur les
missiles de longue et moyenne portée
avec mais basé sur le sol
ce problème en d'ailleurs s'est posée au
moment où les américains ont quitté le
traité idoine et n'ont pas accepté la
proposition de que vous avez fait
monsieur le président à l'époque d'un
moratoire réciproque avec un des moyens
des vérifications adéquates alors les
états unis nous ont fait d'autres
propositions sur le travail en commun
sur la réduction des risques militaires
sur la transparence la prédictabilité et
ses propositions ses suggestions des
états unis sont très proches des
suggestions que nous avons avancé
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires américains
et de nos partenaires de l'otan mais
tout cela dans la dalle eux répondent et
se cherche et extraits du paquet que
nous proposions
il ya deux aspects qui sont abordés tels
a abordés tels que les questions de
sécurité haut dans le ciel
sur la mer de contact entre les
militaires des
lignes rouges téléphonique civile
deux mécanismes de prévention
d'incidents militaire dangereux donc
notre impression générale est que les
collègues et ses deux prendre le paquet
de propositions que la russie leur âge
avancé et d'en extraire
certaines choses qui nous semblent
secondaires qui bien sûr permettrait de
réduire les risques d'une certaine
manière mais qu'ils ne les mettraient en
rien de la liberté des états unis et de
l'otan sur la répartition des forces sur
l'espace de le temps et de l'espace si
vous voulez dire si vous voulez
avoisinant le temps est donc
plus nos partenaires nous pose la
condition et qu'ils seraient là d'escale
à deux tours de l'ukraine donc il
faudrait que la russie agissent la
première et donc nous pouvons constater
qu'il y a des petites avancées dans les
réponses de nos partenaires occidentaux
initiative de décembre et le fait que
nous avons
persévéré dans ces ciels initiatives ont
permis aux états unis là où à nos
partenaires le temps de tenir compte de
certaines de nos jeux
propositions en termes de contrôle des
armements et de
baisse sur une idée ou de contrôle des
tensions qui peut y avoir
ce travail ce dialogue doit
continuer nous avons réagi de manière
détaillée nous même avons adressé en ce
moment notre réponse qu aux états-unis à
cette 2e reçoit et c'est pourquoi les
états unis d'abord parce que la
dimension de le temps me paraît
secondaire puisque le temps
nous déterminera son action finalement
que par rapport à la position du machine
comme d'ailleurs la conférence de munich
sur la sécurité qui vient de s'achever
et a vu encore une fois tous les
occidentaux s'exprimer pour soutenir la
position conjointe la position conjointe
qui est donc
basé sur la position américaine donc
c'est pour cela que nous nous avons tout
d'abord adressé la réponse que vous avez
validé monsieur le président ou à nos
partenaires américains
dans cette réponse nous avons souligné
la chose je pensais pas elle ça n'est
pas notre proposition n'est pas une
carte
où l'on peut choisir peu ce qui nous
intéresse ça n'est pas non plus un
ultimatum elle s'appuie sur quelque
chose de tout à fait et les dents la
situation dans le monde ne peuvent
toujours se résoudre que de manière
holistique si vous voulez vous en compte
de tous les aspects interdépendants la
situation en ukraine des bronzes donc on
voulait les dit monsieur le président
des relations entre la russie et
l'occident avec en tête les états unis
donc nous avons su gagner encore une
fois
l'initiative de la russie celle de
décembre et un paquet est quelque chose
qui réprésente un
complexe de mesures
ce que nous cherchons dans le dialogue
que nous allons bien sûr poursuivre
c'est les réponses
aux questions qui sont cruciales pour
nous c'est à dire que le temps à son
extension vers l'est ce qu'ils limitent
sa présence sur le continent européen
surtout en europe centrale et orientale
compte tenu des engagements pris au
moment de
premiers accords les premières
déclarations entre la russie et le temps
chaud et notre première notre premier
appel ou plutôt notre première exigence
est d'expliquer pourquoi ce document qui
avait été signé qui lisent et que
personne n'allait renforcer sa sécurité
aux dépens de la sécurité des autres
aujourd'hui ce document signé au plus
haut niveau
et ignorait tout simplement et nos
collègues occidentaux refusent même
d'expliquer ce qu'ils entendaient à
l'époque lorsqu'il signé ce document
pourquoi aujourd'hui n'ont aucune
intention de mettre en oeuvre ses
engagements qu'ils ont le même je vous
pris
votre
demande nous avons envoyé ces documents
à washington anthony blinken m'a passé
un coup de fil pour me signaler que j'ai
pris connaissance de qui notre réponse
qu'il était presque à une rencontre pour
en discuter pour exprimer la position
des états unis pour s'être échangé et
poser question vous avez donné un accord
pour cette réunion qui se tiendra cette
semaine le 24 février à genève et nous
allons nous fonder sur les positions que
vous défendez donc vos contacts avec vos
collègues de bible et le ministère des
affaires étrangères va continuer de
faire
justement j'en parle avec mes collègues
et mon collègue pour américain le
président bozize ats-unis m'a assuré que
le cren
n'allait pas faire partie de l'otan dès
demain et que d'ailleurs il avait eu
possibilité
éventuelle été d'un moratoire mais c'est
parce que peut-être considère que le
crâne n'est pas prête aujourd'hui et ma
réponse était la suivante ça n'est pas
quelque chose que vous céder à la russie
c'est votre liberté d'action puisque
vous
vous attendez que l'ukraine soit prête
pour finalement l'admettre a le temps
alors je ne vois pas où est le
rapprochement avec la position russe
puisque lorsque vous considérait qu'elle
est prête vous allez l'admettre
finalement ce moratoire il est dans
votre intérêt et pas dans le nôtre alors
j'ai également discuté avec le président
français nous avons parlé jusqu'à ligne
2 heures du matin d'ailleurs et tu m'as
dit que la position des américains
allaient bouger quand je lui ai demandé
en poids avait fait l'objet il n'a pas
pu me donner des réponses donc je pense
qu'il faudrait d'abord qu'on comprenne
qu'elle est ce frémissement ce
changement de la position des états unis
puisque votre collègue lierre contraire
a dit publiquement qu'il n'y avait
aucun changement sur les positions de
principe concernant l'élargissement de
l'otan et
là où l'ouverture à d'autres pays y
compris jusque rennes est ce que je
comprends c'est bien monsieur le
président ce malgré les documents
secrets qu'ils sont de plus en plus
publiées dans les médias y compris les
médias occidentaux les documents
d'accord avec la russie d'accord entre
les dunes différents pays occidentaux à
l'époque on le voit dans ces deux
chemins il n'y avait même pas
l'intention de long les pays occidentaux
de détendre le temps vers
l'est et pourtant
monsieur
aujourd'hui réfute cela réfute
l'évidence même les documents qui ont
été publiées les archives un britannique
qui étaient déclassifiés et pourtant
pourtant et refuse de d'affaiblir ne
serait ce qu'un tout petit peu cette
politique des portes ouvertes alors que
pourtant vous avez expliqué à deux
endroits en crise mais cette politique
de portes ouvertes ce n'est pas quelque
chose c'est ce qu'il ya dans le cadre de
l'accord de washington une possibilité
dans le cas de l'unanimité de tous les
membres de l'alliance de proposer un
pays de rejoindre cette alliance si ce
pays correspond aux critères de
l'alliance et si sa présence au sein de
l'alliance augmente le niveau de
sécurité de l'alliance ce deuxième
critère est ignorée par le temps depuis
longtemps en ça nous le savons mais
concernant c'est une nouvelle idée ou
peut-être ce changement de position des
états unis et de leurs alliés
nous sommes d'accord avec la position
que vous avez exprimées vis-à-vis de
monsieur macro et nous nous fondons là
dessus nous devons d'abord comprendre
quel est ce changement les collègues
français nous disent qu'ils comprennent
ton quelles sont ses éventuels
changements ou ses éventuelles
propositions de washington
et donc j'ai prévu un accord avec vous
du coup du téléphone avec le ministre
des affaires étrangères français et j'ai
de montréjeau
collègues français à son star de
faire en sorte que nous puissions
aborder cette question de ce changement
éventuel de position des américains et
des éventuelles propositions ci pourrait
nous faire merci beaucoup je vais passer
la parole à jean tricot êtes je lui
demandais où je prie dieu de nous donner
un aperçu de ce qui s'est passé
en termes de mise en oeuvre des accords
de minsk si vous voulez dire troisième
étape troisième échelon et ensuite une
autre membre du
conseil de sécurité de la fédération de
russie auront l'occasion de s'exprimer
pour expliquer quelle est la situation
dans les républiques populaires de
donetsk et de lougansk messieurs kozak
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président chers collègues
je ne souhaite pas vous fatiguer avec
les détails de ces négociations
extrêmement complexe sur la mise en
oeuvre des accords denise minsk
il est devenu évident aujourd'hui que ni
le cren ni ses alliés occidentaux ne
sont pas intéressés ne parle d'une basse
ils font tout pour que ce conflit
devienne un conflit gelé pour qu'on
puisse pour qu'on puisse reprocher cette
situation à la russie sont déjà parvenus
ce couple
en planter cette idée dans l'opinion
publique occidentale et mondiale que ce
conflit autour du donbass est en conflit
russo européennes et que la
responsabilité pour ce conflit repose
sur les épaules de russie
et de la russie pourtant
cela nous coûte très cher
en voyant des l'aide humanitaire nous
aidons ces territoires parce que nos
citoyens qui sont
aujourd'hui au delà
des
avancées son fils de jeunes et beaucoup
qui se sont créés le chômage baisse 1 il
y a plus de postes vacants que de que de
chômeurs deux fois plus
l'activité prenait le chemin de la
reprise
ça allait plutôt bien et un accord avec
les objectifs économiques poursuivi
alors quand à l'ukraine il est évident
que ni l'ukraine ni l'occident ne veut
régler ce conflit dans le donbass et ils
veulent je laisse aux conflits
lorsque l'on pose une pétition ne
serait-ce qu hypothétique
rôle de basse et comment l'intégrer dans
le cren ils sont stupéfaits ils ne
savent pas comment répondre à cette
question comment intégrer le dôme bas
s'ils ne savent ils baissent les yeux il
ne répondrait en ce qui concerne le
d'une basse
pense qu'il n'est nul besoin d'expliquer
les raisons politiques économiques de
nos dites nous comment se passent les
pourparlers autour des accords de minsk
en quel état sont ces pourparlers
eh bien ces pourparlers sont au niveau
zéro depuis 2015
nous vous le savez les accords de minsk
prévoit un dialogue
sur le statut d'une basse après le
conflit ce dialogue il devait commencer
dès que les armes lourdes aura été
retirée de la ligne de contact les armes
au long avait était retiré
officiellement le 8 mars ce retrait
avait été terminée le 9 mars on devait
commencer le dialogue et sur la fin de
l'année 2015 on aurait dû
avoir des amendements à la constitution
ukrainienne
qui aurait été validé par la population
du dawn va c'est ensuite dans le cadre
de cette constitution amendée des
élections et ensuite la frontière aurait
dû passer sous le contrôle de l'ukraine
malheureusement ce dialogue n'est pas
commencé l'ukraine garde le secret sur
le statut du donbass telle qu'elle
envisage
si nous pouvons en tirer de conclusion
c'est que je pense nous pensons qu'elles
imaginent des
municipalités ordinaire ou ukrainiennes
sans aucun statut particulier et le
trail a réussi à convaincre l'opinion
publique le pouvoir ukrainien
réussi à convaincre l'opinion publique
que cette partie des accords de mines
sur le statut particulier des
républiques de donetsk de lougansk était
inacceptable
il était impossible de le mettre en
oeuvre que si l'on accepté ce précédent
et bien d autres régions de l'ukraine
allait
aller se lancer dans la même dans la
même demandé la même
quête de ton âme isation sur voulait il
existe une telle demande par exemple
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine et ça c'est la
conviction profonde du pouvoir ukrainien
est aujourd'hui de l'opinion publique
place à les pourparlers sur les accords
de mini ce qu un niveau a presque en
chuchotant et reconnaissent que ces
accords sont importantes et en sortant
de la salle il
je décrète
publiquement il déclare publiquement que
c'est d'accorder minsk
son une corde qui les étrangle et qu'il
n'y a aucun moyen de les mettre en
oeuvre alors comme je voulais d'y
déposer dans podium j'ai discuté avec
mon collègue français hier il n'y eut
dit vous me lisez que le pouvoir
ukrainien était prêt à mettre en oeuvre
les accords des ming et a même des
nouvelles idées en ce qui concerne leur
mise en oeuvre et la mise en oeuvre des
élections même selon la formule
steinmeier alors je le répète
cela dure depuis huit ans et le cren
s'est retrouvé dans des situations
parfois comique puisque ils mentent
ouvertement
il parle d accord de mise dans le cas de
groupes de contacts du format normandie
il y à quelque chose qui est écrit sur
le papier c'est écrit en noir et ils
nous disent c'est écrit en blanc alors
moi quelquefois je leur disais peut-être
cet écrit à l'encré invisible ou avec du
lait nous avons soit passé un coup de
fer à repasser de se jeter alors la
russie est une partie du conflit alors
dites nous quelles sont nos obligations
en tant que parties au conflit alors
j'ai demandé si vous considérez que la
russie est à malgré sort aider les
allemands et les français
formulée quelles sont les actions que la
russie pourrait faire et là les français
et les allemands nous rétorque peut-être
que la russie pourrait inventer elle
même on crée elle même des obligations
alors jetez-vous parfois nous disons
bien bien allons nous allons aider
quelle est la situation du d'une base
quel est le rôle du de base c'est ce que
refuse de mettre en oeuvre certaines
parties de ces accords de ministre la
réponse que nous recevons c'est nous ne
savons pas nous ne savons pas comment le
donbass enfreint ces accords est ce que
vous
pouvez nous le dira alors
effectivement et ils n'ont pas de
position ils ne savent pas qu'elles
et quelles seraient les obligations de
la russie qu'elle serait alors et un
temps des éclairs éclairez nous en ce
qui concerne les points 9 11 12 les
accords de minsk il y est inscrit que
les décisions doivent être prises dans
le cadre d'un dialogue non plus tôt dans
le cadre de consultations
avec les représentants de serge league
malgré ce qui est inscrit dans les
accords de minsk
je pense que
la dernière fois on avait même apporté
un dictionnaire d'anglais à berlin et
malgré cela ils considèrent que ça n'est
pas une exigence d'un dialogue direct
avec les représentants de ces ce que ce
qui était ce qui est inscrit ses les
discussions et les consultations et donc
ils considèrent que ça n'est pas un
appel au dialogue direct
donc des consultations et des
discussions ça ne signifie pas un
dialogue direct c'est ça oui absolument
c'est la position des ukrainiens j'ai le
président macro on nous disait il
fallait que cette eau ce dialogue ait
lieu dans le cadre du groupe de contact
sous la surveillance de jeu et c'est eux
et ça aussi c'est un faux problème
puisque effectivement cela n'est pas ce
qu dans le cadre du groupe tripartite de
contact sous le monitoring de le laisser
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
ledl basse avant ses propositions au
groupe de contact répartie et ces
discussions se passent toujours en sous
la surveillance de l'eau et c est
lorsque les représentants d'une basse
s'expriment les ukrainiens ferme les
oreilles
et quand on leur dit
répondez à ces revendications ils disent
eh bien si la russie nous demande nous
répondrons et lorsque la russie cette
question comme ça s'est passé l'année
dernière à berlin à quel moment où
allait amender votre constitution
en accord avec les accords de minsk et
bien c'est l'hystérie en ukraine l'année
dernière il a été dit on ne craint que
la russie avance un ultimatum sur
l'amendement de la constitution
ukrainienne qui est une affaire d
souveraineté ukrainienne et que personne
n'a le droit d'y de 6,1 gérer donc si je
comprends bien les pour le pouvoir de
pieve fusent un dialogue direct avec les
républiques de donetsk et de l'eau dans
ce qu ils disent qu'ils doivent le faire
dans le cadre d'un dialogue avec la
russie et lorsque la russie propose
des mesures pour mettre un homme les
accords de minsk et bien nous avons en
réaction une hystérie et
des paroles sur l'ingérence russe dans
les affaires intérieures de craignait
il fait les essais de nous provoquer
pour ensuite nous accusé d'intervenir on
de singer
les accords de
est-ce que nous pouvons les lire de
manière suivante celle frais ne sont pas
des républiques autoproclamées qui
devrait avancer des propositions c'est
plutôt au pouvoir craignant d'avancer
des propositions sur la mise en oeuvre
des accords de minsk alors ça c'est
effectivement la dernière proposition en
date qui est apparu le 10 février à
berlin alors c'est une sorte de
de jeu chipotage tout l'été au juridique
puisqu'il s'agit
de la constitution ukrainienne il faut
que l'initiative soit dans les monts du
pouvoir ukrainien alors et qu'est ce qui
se passe s'il ya des amendements à ces
initiatives si par exemple les
propositions de l'ukraine sont
complètement absurde or si c'est
complètement délirant et que le dôme
basse à une alternative est ce que cette
alternative cette proposition
d'amendement sera étudiée et bien la
réponse n'est pas très concluante au ils
disent on ne sait pas il baisse les yeux
alors finalement et les ukrainiens se
montre très inventif et invente sans
cesse des schémas pour dire
leur
proposition ne peuvent pas finalement
être discuté plus que c'est un droit
souverain de secret si la russie les met
en question est bien c'est de
l'ingérence ici c'est le d'une base qui
les remet en question et bien ce sont
deux séparatistes qui n'ont qu'à aucune
voix au chapitre et c'est alors
l'ukraine l'a dit et de manière très
inattendue la france l'a soutenu hier
tout et cet aspect clé des accords demi
que ces amendements à la constitution
doivent faire l'objet de consultations
avec les populations de réputés
république populaire de douaniers et des
logan ce qu'est ce que cet aspect est
ignorée absolument cette ignorait
schéma
qui se monte
le juriste comme ça qui se ferme des
oreilles qui ne discute avec personne
qui ne discute pas avec le dos de base
si la russie propose quelque chose eh
bien vous savez quelle sera la réaction
est ensuite le fce dois dire que cette
boîte noire qui est le groupe de
contacts répartis tu serais d'accord
alors c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement si vous voulez dire
artificielle comme mon mode de
fonctionnement aujourd'hui chers
collègues à une dernière
quelle est votre ligne est ce que le
pouvoir d kiev a l'intention de mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk
si les événements
continuent tel qu'il situe du maintenant
jamais il est clair qu'il ne souhaite
faire revenir le nomme basse au sein de
l'ukraine ni dans le cadre des accords
de munich ni hors de ce cadre alors je
voulais répondre à la question est ce
que je peux dire encore quelques mots
sur le débat c'est ce que nous devons
l'accepter ou 120 réussi ou pas c'est un
problème sérieux et alors et qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous en dites
alors
être pour le moment nous allons nous
limiter
à ce qui vient d'être dit
[Musique]
sur la mise en oeuvre des
pourparlers pour la mise en oeuvre des
accords du musc nous nous arrêtons sur
votre évaluation
de ses perspectives futures qui paraît
pas très optimiste
dans le cadre des accords de minsk et
donc on va s'en tenir là pour le moment
et je voudrais maintenant
et la parole directeur du jeu et s'est
présentée nous s'il vous plaît en forme
et nous sur la situation qui
a lieu sur la frontière y compris et
justement les gardes-frontière
comptabiliser le nombre de réfugiés donc
je voudrais avoir un point d'information
sur le point sur la situation à la
frontière
monsieur le président nous constatons
une dégradation de la situation sur les
territoires et républiques populaires de
donetsk et de ligue 1 il y a les tirs
d'artillerie cela menace la vie
et compte tenu de cette situation
il ya un mouvement de réfugiés un flux
vers la frontière russe
selon les informations alors 2 heures du
matin ce matin
enfin voilà en train de suivre ce
conseil de défense à moscou au tour de
vladimir poutine conseil de défense qui
est filmé ce qui est assez rare en tout
cas c'est clairement une mise en scène
puisque les caméras sont branchés
bladimir poutine et tu dis c'est
peut-être la principale information
de ce conseil de défense il étudie la
possibilité de reconnaître les régions
séparatistes en ukraine donc celle de
louhansk et de donetsk à la demande
bruno daroux des séparatistes eux-mêmes
et du parlement russe également